[Applause]
matching drip matching nails
i love it it's
amazing construction worker
oh my god
all right
they look stupid they look so dumb so
goofy
thunderball did you get it no
once you turned into she-hulk i couldn't
pierce that nasty green skin
nasty green nasty shut your mouth
so who is there sketchy
this is
inside marvel new rockstars official
after show for marvel's she-hulk i'm
eric boss and with me are empty and
jessica clements hello friends hey hey
hey
she-hulk just got jumped holy [ __ ]
literally yeah literally let's recap
what happened this episode episode three
jen reels after the leaked video of
abomination fighting wong that we saw in
chiang chi but blonsky says he was taken
against his will nikki looks up wong and
we learned that he at one point worked
for a target
i love how she sets him a first trap of
books hilarious
yeah
and it works he's like where he's like
where's that
when he does arrive he's looking both
ways and i'm like okay so you are
looking for nikki and i hope
i want a love interest for wong i want
to love you i think they've been able to
randomly she's amazing i love her i'd
love to go on a double date with nikki
and wong are you kidding me oh my god
with those two it would be magical
i've got it get out exit out exit out
right now
empty you are now sourced through
supreme
that's how you win bad pun you did it we
see this montage of local news and
social media reactions dragging jen for
repping blonsky but really they're just
looking for a reason to cancel her these
[ __ ] like just like give them and
give them a reason right they already
had these all lined up ready to ready to
trash her we actually see an interview
with blonsky's former attorney gideon
wilson who in the comics is sam wilson's
brother jess is actually going to go
further into this guy in the easter egg
breakdown that's coming out later today
be sure to watch it it's going to be
amazing jess i'm sure you have some hot
takes on on this dude yeah i'm very
confused but i i explain why
that's all we ask so jen's former
co-worker at the d.a dennis bukowski has
hired glk and h to sue his ex-girlfriend
a light elf named roona who impersonated
megan the stallion and this is our first
shout out to the light elves of alfheim
in the mcu alphaim is the final one of
the nine realms yet to be established in
the mcu we're going to talk more about
the light elves later we also meet
briefly mallory book jen's co-worker in
the super human law division played by
hamilton's renee elise goldberg that's
exciting to see her give her a longer
scene please i want to see what she's
all about but anyway wong shows up
looking for nikki doesn't find her but
he talks to jen and he says he confirms
that he did extract blonsky from prison
why to have a worthy opponent as part of
his training to become sorcerer supreme
i have questions about this i thought he
was already sorcerer supreme during the
blip when when stephen strange wasn't
there so maybe there's still some like
trials or some fitness checks that you
have to go through after your service
were supreme i have to re-up my
membership every few months by fighting
some hulked out figure and i'll steal
him from prison
i think wong is just uh which clearly
because he brings up being the
sorcerer's supreme every second he's on
camera i think he just takes it so
literally that he's like i also have to
train for it i already have the job but
i just need to be the best of the best
of the best and i'm like go off yeah go
off my baby
i love him so much i love wong i mean
yes let's just this is this is the era
of wong the summer of wong and i'm here
for it i love hong kong even hulk
addresses it even the even the writers
and she-hulk herself is like
we know you want him
we know you tune in no one's complaining
i love how wong references erasing
everyone's memories during spider-man no
way home and he calls it messy which is
fascinating that he remembers the fact
that this memory wipe happened because
yeah anyway we'll talk about this more
but he offers to send blonsky to the
mirror dimension in the shadow dimension
uh tying back into multiverse madness
and in uh love and thunder the shadow
realm we assume might be the same thing
i don't know if it's the same thing the
dimensions it's the shadow from uh
yu-gi-oh that's what they're talking
about specifically that's what i thought
they were talking about i was thinking
about it i even put it in my breakdown
no i did it i did not put yu-gi-oh at
all in my breakdown
blue eyes white dragon sorry keep going
i think jess needs to release her
yu-gi-oh card rankings exactly
so roona the light elf messes with
everybody this episode she pretends to
be dennis she pretends to be pug or boy
pug she says sexually harassing women
okay
oh my god literally a career ender
she could have literally must protect at
all
pug pug looked at them and said you guys
know me he's like you know me
i gave you all the map to the best
bathroom for pooping you guys know me
i'm a good man i know
well he gave too many people that map
empty and now that's the only bad people
long line basically everyone's in
tommy's office and everyone's using the
same bucket in tommy's office and now
they're all pissed look while tommy's
away we all use the same bucket at
thomas
for pooping yeah i mean you know what's
gonna happen in the mcu unfortunately is
all the [ __ ] are gonna say hey i
didn't send that dick pic uh light up
it's true i'm like okay it's the new my
account was hacked it's gonna be a light
house it's a lot it's precedent in law
now it's like all right now light elves
can
do bad [ __ ] all right whatever
so we see polanski's parole hearing we
meet blonsky's seven soul mates uh some
adoring pen pals wearing wreaths a true
manson family situation i'm sure you
guys caught that reaction shot where he
hulked out and they're all like
this is what i've been waiting
oh my god he looks like a giant fish man
and every and all of them were
immediately like swoon and i was like no
the shape of water uh won an oscar
that's different that's different and we
know that's different that man's
different that man's fine as hell but
this
jess i don't know what you're talking
about our boy claims that he's changed
emotionally physically metaphysically
spiritually karmically cosmically and
interdimensionally which what the hell
does he mean by that this guy hasn't
been other dimensions so we know wong
what have you been doing with him taking
him to that hand dimension that doctor
strange went to
describe every part of me i'll set up
for seven
but i'll take in infinite hands that's a
good that's a good that's a good
impression of him i'll give you that i
like that one that one's good i'm
working on it my my british accent
changes every time you know there's
something people watching like no
that's australian yeah i don't know
so we learned that blonsky is a compound
where he's going to set up a meditation
retreat wow
that's never been a start of a sentence
that i want to finish right but dennis
and runa have their trial we learned
that rooney is the daughter of an
elephant diplomat the judge denies her
diplomatic immunity when she tries to
quote thor and odin with that asgard's
not a place as a people and then rooney
impersonates a judge for good measure
wong shows up to the parole board
hearing late and he tells them that he
did take blonsky from prison but despite
offering him some asylum at camera taj
blonsky insisted on returning to prison
it sounds like wong's just making [ __ ]
up for blossom he just likes his
sparring buddy but i don't know bolosky
hulks out proves he's in control and is
able to talk uh and jen testifies that
dennis is a delusional loser capable
being duped by an impersonator and the
judge rules in dennis's favor making
these stallion cameos in the back of the
courtroom i love it i love it but this
is the first of you know this is not the
first of many mcu cameos that we see
elon musk was an iron man 2. this is
true that we've had was he's a weird
celebrity i can't remember that
the fight on the on the road there um
he's talking about larry ellison showed
up in that same movie too like because
they had the oracle
you know biodome thing right like so
technically like beyonce is also mcu
canon yeah oh absolutely wong oh my god
this oh my god they should have got
beyonce too that would have been
incredible you think beyonce would have
showed up beyonce's too busy with her
last album she's like oh no
she showed up in pink panther she thinks
she's too good for movies ever since
pink panther which is the worst thing
she's ever been in and i will say it out
loud
the worst thing she's ever been in
wow those are some harsh words jess
marshmallows
i'll give her i'll give her um i'll give
her any i'll give her dream girls was
good okay
pink panther wasn't good with her in it
austin powers gold member was okay
i love gold i'm not a woman i love these
movies i'm saying beyonce in the movies
is what i don't like
i love the movies me and beyonce can
talk i it's her it's her acting which is
me and her have a beef about the parole
board agrees to release blonsky so long
as he wears an inhibitor and then jin
gets attacked by this crew who robbed an
asgardian con construction site it
sounds like they're the version of the
wrecking crew from the comics they tried
to steal jen's blood they work for a
mysterious boss and in the postcard it
seems jonah megan these stallion twerk
because why not why why wouldn't you
that's post-credits
my favorite part about it is she got the
one line that every mega italian fan
would say is i kill for you megan
and she was like okay settle down i was
like that'd be the first thing i say to
her that would be the first thing i'd
say to her about who do you want me to
kill
it's like don't forget you are a hulk
i'm very terrified so please stop
before we get to the question of who
this wrecking crew is and who they work
for mt do you have uh some fun news to
share with us guys do not forget to head
on over to new rockstarsmerch.com to
grab our newest latest obsession shirt
to lady justice inspired by the she-hulk
series this limited edition shirt will
not be available forever so be sure to
grab one before they're gone faster than
an abomination on parole and when you do
purchase the latest subscription shirt
you unlock the ability to get a custom
shout out that will appear right here on
inside marvel so be sure to check out
all of our amazing merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com but jess what is
our first question for this episode
our first question is who is the
wrecking crew and who do they work for
hmm
yes where are their daddies and what do
they do
i can answer that
i can answer that the wrecking crew is a
recurring group of super villains who
first appeared in the defenders comics
in 1974 but really they've showed up
again and again fighting the avengers
spider-man fantastic four the x-men she
all for the most part they're known as
villains to thor they are made up of the
wrecker aka the prisoner dirk garthwaite
who gets powers when his crowbar is
enchanted by the non-queen carnilla and
uh she actually thought he was loki a
lightning bolt strikes his crowbar
transforms guard weights along with the
ex-physicist who asked for his help dr
elliott franklin franklin becomes
thunderball who carries mace the kind of
ball and chain thing that you see the
there's some other prisoners henry camp
camp becomes a bulldozer who wears the
armored helmet and then a brian koluski
who becomes piledriver and comics sees
giant hands here it kind of looks like
he wears these armored gauntlets that
glow they first fight the defenders in
luke cage but then over the years
they're always breaking out of prison
they fight thor a lot and really um any
one of the other marvel heroes from time
to time with this episode of she-hulk
the mcu looks to be changing their
origin a bit to something closer to i
guess adrian tombs crew and spider-man
oh yeah i got one of these becoming crew
that vibes yeah they're picking up the
wrong [ __ ] right and they don't know how
to use it instead of these men being
enchanted physiologically by carnila it
just kind of looks like they acquired
some asgardian tech and now they're
working for someone who wants jennifer
walters blood which is interesting it's
kind of set up in episode one with that
close-up of bruce incinerating her blood
samples showing us how precious of a
resource hulk blood is and how it
shouldn't fall into the wrong hands thor
eleven thunder explored the effect of
new asgard and earth's society new
asgard is now a tourist destination with
enchanted boats and inappropriate thanos
ice cream king valkyrie has to sit in on
these conferences with all these
international diplomats there was that
news ticker and spider-man uh no way
home mentioning political turmoil in new
asgard and now we're seeing how the
light elf aruna who is one of the
citizens of new asgard she's using
asgardian shape-shifting sorcery the
kind loki uses to defraud people in
america so
in general asgardians uh technology and
magic is just kind of screwing with
society in all kinds of ways this is a
new version of leftover chittari tech
after the battle of new york so let's
speculate what is the wrecking crew's
mcu origin i don't know i think the
recent crisis with gore when new
asgard's leaders and parents were just
distracted by gore snatching their kids
and thor valkyrie jane and korg went off
to omnipotent city then on to the shadow
room to deal with it the that colony
really had its guard down and visitors
there at the time might have swiped some
enchanted construction tools and clearly
these guys just aren't very good at
using these clearly you know like
they're they're falling all over
themselves uh i think they then might
have shopped them to some of the various
arms dealers throughout the mcu we know
the power broker sharon carter from
magicboard now she's exonerated after
the falcon the winter soldier there's
the very silent partners that she is
connected with in the comics the
wrecking crew has worked under the hood
parker robbins we know he's uh showing
up in ironheart we think it's gonna be
anthony ramos character but i suspect
their boss will have some thunderbolts
or daredevil connection maybe wilson
fist kingpin maybe val one of them could
be sharon carter's buyer whom she called
on the phone if they are like i feel
like those two would be the most eager
to acquire weaponized fluid like super
soldier serum and hulkblood we know in
the mcu the hulk project really was uh
rooted in that super soldier project uh
base that blonsky was talking to ross
about in that 2008 hulk movie i really
think kingpin and val might have been
the ones who gave holloway the money
many many money to set up the superhero
law division at glknh to exonerate
people like blonsky and then maybe
groups like the wrecking crew report to
them but i want to know both of your
thoughts there's really
sky's the limit with options they could
be working for no i think that um
this is setting up something that was
teased at the end of the incredible hulk
sort of with um with the leader because
the leader had a room a massive room
full of the hulk's blood that the hulk
he sent him one sample and the leader
was like alright i'm just gonna make a
bunch because i want to cure humanity of
all the sicknesses of the world and the
bruce is like no we have to burn this
room and like we see off-screen in the
avengers prelude comic uh i believe
number seven that um the leader like
tries to get um natasha to take all the
blood so he can form a new society form
this new world that is ruled by people
of power and influence and i think that
we're seeing that come into fruition in
this show because like these people want
jen's blood specifically because it can
give you superpowers it can give you the
ability to become a super soldier and i
think that there's a possibility here
that a val working on behalf of hydra is
trying to fill the world with chaos by
by flooding the world with a bunch of
super powered people so that hydra could
come in and try to take over the world
slowly but like oh man we need the
sokovia accords again like because like
well that was really going to help us
out and like we just threw that away we
need to the to control people and have
our own avengers in every state and to
just you know keep the world safe but
we're actually hydra we're going to take
over the world um so i think that this
is um what they might be setting up here
with this uh gen blood situation but
what do you think jess i agree i well
when i first i think it's a good idea to
bring the leader in especially if we're
gonna bring in this much of an
incredible hulk why not bring the leader
in so i did pitch like this might be the
leader but if we're talking like i'm not
trying to turn this into rogue theory
but if we want to make this wild i agree
with what both of you are saying
ultimately uh but also oh
i haven't seen those i haven't seen
those in so long give them back
give them back
give them back their minds
also well to also add on to what boss
said first i i just think wilson fisk is
so
messy and val isn't val is very pretty
clean about getting her people so i
don't know if they'd be that close
working together but i do want to see
them be working for leapfrog and why i
think i want them to be working for
leapfrog is i want leapfrog to be a rich
version opposite of kind of what he kind
of was in the comics i want him to like
make up for what his dad did and have
his own pair of goons and i just want
these to be the goons that he hires and
i want because these the wrecking crew
is such a joke and i'm sorry for people
that love the wrecking crew can still
love them but also say that they're
fools
they're fools and also they're they're
they're villains that wear their symbol
on their chest
like t-shirts not like an actual car
they're just best friends okay
they went they went to like a place and
was like hey can you print these on a
shirt for us you want a circle with a
giant w hat
on a shirt please that'd be great the
flag smashers didn't really even do that
did they they didn't have like a shirt
that said flax smash like they they were
that's fine i just think it's kind of
like cartoony to make t-shirts
i think it's sweet i think it's they all
hang out in a van together and they like
and
they did like the power rangers set up
and then all got knocked in one
one push so it's like that's why i think
for leapfrog it would make the most
sense keep it chaotic with another
chaotic have them just be working for
like a mediocre mid villain versus like
wilson fisk i think he learned his
lesson from the uh the jumpsuits or the
tracksuit mafia uh where it's like they
can be really messy let's not make messy
messy again that's a good point there
would be a lot of uh sloppy groups who
are comedic working for uh morgan
purple's a fist but i can't see wilson
wanting the wrecking crew to take her
blood because like i think at this point
this dude's blind right he should be
blind at the end of hawkeye because like
he sort of shoots him off screen so like
oh you think he's assuming he's blind so
maybe you think he would hire
a better team than the wrecking crew the
wrecking crew was actually worse than
the traffic looks kind of like these
days
that is true that is true that is true
the way he left the third season of
daredevil he has nothing so he could be
that he might have met the working crew
in prison because they met in prison but
i still like the wrecking crew just so
messy they can't be working for val
that would never hire those those fools
i mean maybe there's a lot of different
crews maybe there's like i don't know
six different crews and these guys we're
just kind of working our way through all
the different slot slop towns i think
you mentioned it and we didn't even
bring up the fact that we're getting red
hood in the iron in iron heart so why
wouldn't he be working for the red hood
crime syndicate that we see on
the hood so it's like it's dc
oh oh not red hood sorry oh god sorry it
is
there's too many hoods too many too many
too many properties but you did bring up
the hood and how he worked for the hoods
crime syndicate in
uh
in the comics briefly so i wouldn't i
wouldn't be surprised if he shows up in
iron heart as like
like a team of weird villains
yeah i think it's
i love this idea of the leader as well i
mean i'm ready for him to come back and
like if blossom come back the leader can
totally come back i'm just wondering
would it be hydra that he's connected
with could it be the intelligentsia are
we gonna see like a lineup of super
villains because we know the the leaders
connected with that i'd love to see
other groups you know just like a couple
different uh leagues of villains who are
all kind of like
work in different angles right um it's
just who would be more interested i
guess hydra has a history of super
soldier serum and wanting their hands on
that kind of thing to create an army of
you know brainwashed groups obsessed man
like obsessed with that super soldier
serum they want more freaking red skull
was like the first super soldier serum
um recipient although he got a really
bad concoction and so they're probably
just like hey let's be like our pal red
skull or god let's make us all super
powered could they be working with
southpaw since we know that southpaw is
holding hallways like oh spoilers in the
comic is holding holloway's
granddaughter do you think that they
could be working for southpaw who's on
the streets right now and she's like
that's
blood give me that blood
i wonder
if holloway could like there's something
wrong with south power like she's sick
he's like i need her blood so that um
she can be really cool and have a big
arm or whatever damn it that's the only
way i'd i'd give sympathy to holden too
is because i like southpaw i hate him
right now and i don't think i think he's
good he's up to no good he is sketched
and that's the only way i'll like like
him is if he's just trying to protect
his granddaughter here's here's a high
take dracula what if dracula wants blue
baby and we get some dracula business
going on it sets up blade baby because
we have blades coming
true next year that is so true
i never thought about a vampire vampire
angle that is such a good idea because
like what is that like mountain dew
flavor like with gamma blood it's like
mmm delicious i've never had this it's
covered red code red mountain dew code
red but like yeah i feel like it would
be delicious
that's a good idea oh my god that's so
good i drank a mountain dew code red
exclusively i don't think i drank water
freshman year of high school your
kidneys love it more than more right
take little sips
that's why i piss blood
anyway
keep it to yourself as long as it's not
in tommy's bathroom office i don't care
what you do anyway hey let's talk about
our sponsors helix sleep when you got a
big day at court you're gonna want to
get some great sleep the night before
and nothing helps you get perfect night
sleep like a helix mattress i have a
helix mattress that does mt recently
producer zach producer john got a helix
mattress they got separate ones they did
they got a bunk bed mattress they sleep
helix sleep is a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete it matches your
body type and your sleep preferences to
the perfect matches for you everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
burn mattresses matches is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent some morning aches and pains
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers producer zach took the helix
quiz and was matched to the midnight
deluxe mattress because he's a side
sleeper that needed a softer mattress
and now he doesn't wake up with a sore
shoulder or neck like he did with the
other mattresses that he used to have
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2021 by gq and
wired magazine so here's what you gotta
do go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
inside marvel all right back to the
episode i want to ask you two do you
think wong remembers the memory wipe
spell from spiderman no way home
actually i had this question too and so
then i went back and rewatched no way
home and technically uh he brings it up
to he basically asked wong for
permission right before wong leaves he's
like do you remember the party that
happened at the karma tosh he's like no
exactly like
and he's like just leave me out of it i
don't want to deal with it so he's aware
of the spell before it was created so i
think he's aware that everyone's mind
got wiped about peter parker or
spider-man and then the whole thing
happened and then everyone got wiped
knowing who peter parker is so i think
he still knows the original spell that
was supposed to take place of like
everyone for getting uh spider-man
i like that just location that makes
sense and that doesn't make a lot of
sense but also like the spell was very
specific to peter parker and the
knowledge that he is spider-man like
everyone probably saw the huge cracks
over uh the statue of liberty so like
that's probably people's memories but
they probably have no idea why it
happened or like if it's related to
peter parker in any way so i think that
wong probably saw the crack she's like
those are the dark borders that i was
talking about i told strange about uh so
something happened with that spell
something terribly wrong
but i can't remember so all i know is
that the spell is bad we should probably
not do it
again so i don't know i i love that he
calls it messy right like i think wong
as sorcerer supreme is dealing with all
like the the plot holes that now exist
as sort of you just can kind of see how
confused people are like people have
this fog in their head of like they know
spiderman was part of it i think he
might have taken off his mask at some
point but i just can't remember who was
under that mask like that kind of mass
amnesia is what he's referring to by
messi's like it doesn't make sense this
episode specifically i think the third
episode does the most with the writers
the writers are having fun for she-hulk
for sure i think this episode is the
writers there is a mention that jessica
gow said they won't let us make fun of
marvel
she did an interview that was like we're
not allowed to make fun of marvel too
much and i think this was a little joke
nod at marvel by being like no one
understands the repercussions of what
happened in that spell and it is so hard
to understand so i think they just wrote
like it's messy to like also be a sly
nod to everyone that watched the movie
that was like wait if this happened then
why isn't all these things happening i
really hope deadpool gets to make fun of
barbara a little bit though
hopefully yeah they better unleash him
and like team him up with jen and let
jen also make fun of right because
marvel deserves to be made to be fair
jessica gow they're they're making fun
of marvel was like kind of rough it was
like them being kind of mean
the crux of it you know i agree all
right let's talk about light elves uh
what could be their mcu background i
know empty you have some opinions about
light elves yeah i think that the
sovereign are evolved versions of the
light elves because we know in guardians
2 like they're obsessed with evolving
their actual bodies to be the perfect
beings and like they
i think they live on six suns that are
covered in um something called dyson
spheres which are like a completely
fictional scientific thing that harlow
and basically like scientists if they
could
cover the sun in this like technology
sphere could harness the power of the
sun and have infinite energy forever
basically well until the sun burns out
um so i think that the sovereign
themselves are a genetically modified
version of this woman and like she's
just like unmodified she's just a pure
light elf and she's living on asgard but
that's just my weird thing i think that
um the light elves
are just all about light like just like
the dark elves are all about darkness um
which is why she can change her
appearance because she's just
manipulating light around herself
because like all right i'm a light elf
we could just
create illusions sort of like um i'm
forgetting her name sprite from um
from from eternals or loco i like that
uh theory empty i think that's a really
cool idea i my thinking is that like the
way the realms have been depicted in the
in the mcu when it comes to like the
asgardian realms of the nine realms uh
they seem to be like other planets
uh and like didn't we see vanaheim or
whatever in the uh right in thor two and
thor the dark world we know moospelheim
it was like searchers realm it just
seemed to be like another place uh not a
people though i just find it interesting
that like this family of light elves was
on asgard and like this was like another
race of people that they might have been
basically the ambassadors
from alfheim living on new asgard at the
time the way that like an ambassador
will bring their family to
uh to asgard and then it got destroyed
and they just got like stuck with the
asgardian people maybe like the people
the other light elves were all basically
eradicated and killed and now she ends
up on new asgard but like i have to
wonder is uh you know we were talking
before we started rolling
how weird she is she's like a weird
little trickster
like maybe the light elves could be
super old and this woman is actually
like super young she's like a child yeah
uh
the lighthouse 100 i agree with that 100
100 especially because uh actually going
back really quick i do think that like
the nine realms still have since odin
conquered them i feel like
maybe odin was nice enough to give each
of them like a correspondent for each of
the worlds just so it's like we need to
still live in harmony i own you guys but
like you guys can't fight me so bring
your respective people and we'll have
talks every now and then and i think
that's maybe her dad but i also think
like most countries if you're like just
someone that's born somewhere else and
then you raise your family on another
country or another planet here in this
world it would be another planet i think
she just lived
like such a trickery like in nel uh in
alfheim i feel like the elves are very
sweet very nice each of them have
different properties of what they do and
i feel like they're really smart and
work technologically and this elf
specifically runa is just the trickster
because she was raised in asgard to new
asgard to now like earth so now she's
just like i can be the trickery one i
think she's a bad example for what the
light elves are and she's not at all a
good representative for what lineups are
so i think she is young she is very
young and she's just all about tricking
people and being an [ __ ]
i just don't because i think we're all
gonna look at this and be like oh these
are how light elves act and i'm like no
in the comics
they're very sweet and they're genuine
and actually they were like the easiest
one to conquer so i don't want bruno to
be the example of what they are they're
all just annoying elves and they're just
shape-shifting into just stealing [ __ ]
all the time like sorry edit all this
out but like jesus christ i was like
runa sucks
she really does suck but i love her
i hope we see her in secret invasion
she's lost her home she's lost
everything you gotta imagine a little
kid will be a little trickster like that
right but i don't like how she she tries
to get pug cancelled like she's right
yeah exactly she's like let that be your
warden and i'm like let that
also a warning in front of everybody
that just saw you do that we know you're
lying
she's not smart about her tricks either
that's what makes me think she's a kid
is i'm like you're really bad about your
tricks you're getting caught 24 7. dude
all right let's talk about blonsky's
compound oh uh so i want to know what
you guys think he's planning also do we
think like the footage from the trailer
where jen is like wearing her sundress
on that farm do we think that's his
compound oh that could
well yeah interesting i always took that
as like a country club because i think
the compound is where he's doing the
group therapy and in the windows in the
trailer it's all a lot of foliage and
there's not as many foliage on that golf
course but titania is in both scenes so
that's why you could be right because
titania is on the is a part of the group
therapy and is uh seen
in the background on the golf course so
you could be right but i think
that's where
we see a compound in the trailers
is the group therapy
i just find it interesting like we've we
just saw a cult and moon night with
arthur harrow right yeah like are these
cults aware of each other are they
competing cults
the seven wives that is manson great 100
i also think it's not to be that person
that's just so like you guys know like
i'm woke as hell but i'm like i think
it's also the writers just making fun of
polygamy like making fun of polyamorous
relationships but i it is like
definitely like be a part of me
and i'm like but they're not evil
like manson they're not evil like the
one we know of we don't know that is
true
that is true that is true i think that
this whole like seven soul mates thing
is probably just like a a foreshadowing
on marvel studios part because they keep
bringing up i'm gonna retire back with
my seven soul mates on a compound i
think that this compound like at the end
of the day like bonski of course like he
has his own like retreat thing in the
show but i think that the real compound
that he's talking about is gonna be
either with the thunderbolts or like the
dark avengers or something where like
it's him and seven other bad guys um
maybe gamma powered bad guys uh maybe
we're looking at um was it gamma flight
in the comics um i don't know but like
i'm thinking like it's an actual team of
bad guys that he's like secretly like
trying to wink at a nod um tease to us
brandon brandon mentioned once that he
was like i think the seven uh are
representing the seven people for the
thunderbolts the seven other people for
the thunderbolts and i was like i would
like that but also watch it just be
his
i just think it's the seven wives at
this point
yeah i think it's gotta just be his
wives i just kind of wanna know like
what their moral alignment is you know
like
i can't trust them i don't know if
they're gonna be like as evil and
violent as they were as he was in the
2008 film but like i have to think
there's just something creepy i mean
like i can't believe that the parole
board is like oh sure manson vibes
approved like
they're wearing wreaths
like that's freaking weird it ain't
illegal to start a cult i guess
not illegal to be married to seven
people which actually i think it is it
is illegal to be ladies and gentlemen as
i say it out loud well yeah you can't be
married to mostly legally legally even
religiously i just watched keep sweet so
i don't know how this works anymore
kelly and i just finished keep saying
that this works anymore legally
you definitely cannot you definitely
watch me i'm gonna get married to eight
people but yeah it's it's
yeah it's so interesting also it's like
not to be that weird person but if they
do each have an offspring to him will
they be making more hulks
will they be making more abominations is
that maybe his motive
to make a picture it's crazy because
it's not like in the real world your dna
doesn't get affected by [ __ ] that
happens to you uh while you're alive
that's like the lamarck theory of
evolution versus the darwinian theory of
evolution like it's it's just things
that already exist in your body give you
an evolutionary advantage and that's
what you pass on to your offspring but
in the mcu it affects their dna right
their dna is affected which doesn't make
any sense but that's depiction so we
think they're still up to no good i just
think they're nice wives maybe i'm
giving blonsky too much of a pass i
genuinely think he did
i mean you can only pass it on if like
the what enables your superpower is a
mutation right but i don't think they're
gonna make hulk mutants maybe they will
say that like the
banner family has a mutation and then uh
you know blotsky also has a mutation i
just think they're gonna have to draw
the line somewhere with who is a mutant
and who isn't and i think they're gonna
say that like gamma-ray people are just
a different thing yeah i don't think
they're gonna touch that too much in
she-hulk i think she-hulk has so much
that i think kevin feige probably at one
point yeah if i get one point it's
probably gonna be like hey
stop releasing all this information
because we have to answer it eventually
we'll leave it there for this episode of
she-hulk it's so much fun chatting this
show with with you two um and again be
sure to check out jess's breakdown that
should be coming out in a couple hours
if it's not already on the channel she's
been doing such a such a great job
breaking down all the easter eggs and
finding all the hidden goodies and all
these episodes so be sure to check that
out follow jessica at lulu underscore
clements follow mt at mastertainment
follow me at eavos be sure to subscribe
to inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast subscribe to new rockstars thank
you so much for watching we'll see you
next week bye everybody
you